la cayolle une double personnalité
étonnante le jour honorable marchands de
bibliothèque à montpellier et la nuit
redoutable chef de bande à paris cailhol
s'est d'ailleurs présenté comme un
simple comparses ne connaissant rien à
la faire et puis il a compris que s'ils
voulaient sauver sa tête aux assises ils
avaient tout intérêt à reconnaître que
les policiers étaient maintenant maître
du jeu et que seule la libération du
baron empain pouvait lui permettre
d'échapper à la guillotine
d'où l'incroyable coup de téléphone
passé par alain cayol depuis un bureau
de la police judiciaire à ces hommes à
ceux qui détenaient le baron empain
nous allons revenir en détail sur tous
ces points qu'un auteur de séries noires
n'aurait jamais osé imaginer
mais d'abord les circonstances de la
libération du ballon du baron empain
avec christian barquisseau arts place de
l'opéra un homme sort de la station de
métro et entre drogue store c'est le
baron empain
aussi extraordinaire que cela puisse
paraître le baron traverse les boutiques
les bars les restaurants descend
jusqu'aux cabine téléphonique un long
trajet sans que personne ne le remarque
pas même la préposée qui lui vend le
jeton de téléphone soixante trois jours
de captivité l'ont bien changé là il
fait son numéro à l'autre bout du fil
une femme tremble d'émotion
reconnaissant la voix de son mari
libérer quelques minutes plus tôt dans
une ruelle d'ivry ses ravisseurs lui ont
donné juste l'argent nécessaire pour
prendre le métro et téléphoné à sa fin
le temps d'arriver de l'avenue foch et
ce sont les retrouvailles après 63 jours
de captivité
le baron en pas très fatigué demande aux
policiers de rentrer d'abord chez lui il
parlera après avoir un peu récupéré 23
heures le commissaire ottavioli chef de
la brigade criminelle arrive avenue foch
il faut pour lui tout faire maintenant
pour capturer toute la bande des
ravisseurs le baron livre alors les
renseignements sur les circonstances et
le déroulement son rap un peu après
minuit le commissaire ottavioli sort du
domicile de l'industriel et celle
appelée des journées après prévenir qu'
il valait mieux libérer le baron est ce
qu'il ya une remise de rançon
certainement est ce que vous pensez
qu'il pourra nous parler et qui lui
permettent pas nous dire quelques mots
ainsi le désir je pense que oui
[Musique]